we mentioned that the universe is kind
of like a compiler
uh you know the entirety of it the whole
evolution is kind of a kind of
compilation
maybe our us human beings are kind of
compilers um
let me ask the the old absurd question
that i didn't ask you last time which is
uh
what's the meaning of it all is there a
meaning like if you asked a compiler why
what would a compiler say what's the
meaning of life what's the meaning of
life
uh you know i'm prepared for not to mean
anything
here we are all biological things
programmed to
survive and and propagate our
our dna um and maybe the universe is
just a
just a computer and you just go until
entropy takes over the world and or
takes over the universe and then you're
done
um i don't think that's a very
productive way to live your life
if so and so i prefer to bias towards
the other way which is saying
the world has the universe has a lot of
value and
i take uh i take happiness out of other
people
and a lot of times part of that's having
kids but also the relationships you
build with other people
and so uh the way i try to live my life
is like what can i do that has value how
can i move the world forward how can i
take what i'm good at and like bring it
bring it into the world and how can i
i'm one of these people that likes to
work really hard and
be very focused on the things that i do
and so
if i'm going to do that how can it be in
a domain that actually will
matter right because a lot of things
that we do we find ourselves in the
cycle of like okay i'm doing a thing
i'm very familiar with it i've done it
for a long time i've never done anything
else
but i'm not really learning and i'm not
really
i'm keeping things going but there's a
there's a younger generation that can do
the same thing maybe even better than me
right maybe if i actually step out of
this and jump into something
i'm less comfortable with it's scary but
on the other hand
it gives somebody else a new opportunity
it also then puts you back in learning
mode
and that can be really interesting and
one of the things i've learned is that
when you go through that that first
you're deep into imposter syndrome
but when you start working your way out
you start to realize hey well there's
actually a method to this and
and now i'm able to add new things
because i bring different perspective
and this is one of the
the good things about bringing different
kinds of people together
diversity of thought is really important
and um if you
can pull together people that are coming
at things from different directions
you often get invasion and i love to see
that that aha moment where you're like
oh what we've like really cracked this
this is something that
nobody's ever done before and then if
you can do it in the context where it
adds value other people can build on it
it helps move the world then that's what
that's what really excites me
so the that kind of description of the
magic of the human experience do you
think we'll ever create that
in like an agi system you think we'll
be able to create uh give
give ai systems a sense of meaning where
they operate in this kind of world
exactly in the way you've
described which is they interact with
each other they interact with us humans
sure well so i mean i why why are you
being so
uh speciesist right all right so
so agis versus bionet
or something you know um yeah you know
uh what are we but machines right we're
just programmed to
run our we have our objective function
that we're optimized for
right and so we're doing our thing we
think we have purpose but do we really
yeah right i'm not prepared to say that
those newfangled agis
have no soul just because we don't
understand them right and i think that
would be
um when that when they exist uh that
would be very premature to
uh look at a new thing through your own
lens without fully understanding it
um you might be just saying that because
ai systems in the future would be
listening to this and then oh yeah
exactly you don't want to say please be
nice to me you know when skynet
skynet kills everybody please spare me
so why is
wise uh look ahead thinking yeah but i
mean i i think that
people will spend a lot of time worrying
about this kind of stuff and i think
that what we should be worrying about is
how do we make the world better and the
thing that i'm most scared about with
agis is not that um
that necessarily the skynet will start
shooting everybody with lasers and stuff
like that to
use us for calories the thing that i'm
worried about is that
um humanity i think needs a challenge
and if we get into a mode of not having
a personal challenge not having a
personal contribution
whether that be like you know your kids
and seeing what they grow
into and helping helping guide them
whether it be
your community that you're engaged in
you're driving forward whether it be
your work and the things that you're
doing the people you're working with and
the products you're building and
the contribution there if people don't
have a objective
i'm afraid what that means and um
i think that this would lead to a rise
of the worst part of people
right instead of people striving
together and trying to make
uh the world better it could degrade
into
a very uh unpleasant world but
but i don't know i mean we hopefully
have a long ways to go before we
discover that
unfortunately we have pretty on the
ground problems with the pandemic right
now and so i think we should be focused
on that as well
yeah ultimately just as you said you're
optimistic i think it helps for us to be
optimistic
because that's uh fake it until you make
it
yeah well and why not right what's the
other side right so i mean
uh uh i'm not personally a very
religious person but i've heard people
say like
oh yeah of course i believe in god of
course i go to church because
if god's real you know i want to be on
the right side of that if it's not real
doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter and so you know
that's that's a fair way to do it
um yeah i mean the same thing with uh
with the nuclear deterrence all
you know global warming all these things
all these threats natural engineer
pandemics
all these threats we face i think it's
uh
it's paralyzing to be terrified
of all the possible ways we could
destroy ourselves i think it's much
better
or at least productive to be hopeful and
to engineer
defenses against these things to
engineer a future where
like you know see like a positive future
and engineer that future
yeah well and i think that's another
thing to think about as
you know a human particularly if you're
young and trying to figure out what it
is that you want to be when you grow up
like i am
um i'm always looking for that uh the
the question then is how do you want to
spend your time
and right now there seems to be a norm
of being a consumption culture
like i'm going to watch the news and and
revel in how horrible everything is
right now
i'm going to go find out about the
latest atrocity and find out all the
details of like
the terrible thing that happened and be
outraged by it um
you can spend a lot of time watching tv
and watching the
new sitcom or whatever people watch
these days i don't know
um uh but that's a lot of hours right
and those are hours that if you're
turn into being productive learning
growing experiencing uh you know when
the pandemic's over going exploring
right he it leads to more growth and i
think it leads to more optimism and
happiness because you're
you're you're building right you're
building yourself you're building your
capabilities you're building your
viewpoints you're building your
perspective
and um i think that a lot of the cons
the consuming of other people's messages
leads to
kind of a negative viewpoint which you
need to be aware of what's happening
because that's also important but
there's a balance that um i think
focusing on
creation is is a very valuable thing to
do
yeah so what you're saying is people
should focus on uh working on the
sexiest field of them
all which is compiler design exactly hey
you could go work on machine learning
and be crowded out by the
thousands of graduates popping out of
school that all want to do the same
thing or you could work in the
place that people will overpay you
because there's not enough smart people
working in it
and uh here at the end of moore's law
according to some people
yeah uh actually the software is the
hard part too yeah
uh i mean optimization is is truly
uh truly beautiful and also on the
youtube side or education side
uh you know it's there's uh it'd be nice
to have some material that shows the
beauty of
compilers yeah yeah that's that's
something
so that's a call for uh for people to
create that kind of content as well
chris uh you're one of my favorite
people to talk to
i is such a huge honor that you would
waste your time
talking to me uh i've always appreciated
thank you for having me
today the the the truth is you spent a
lot of time talking to me
just on you know walks and other things
like that so it's great to catch up
thanks man
you